Hi!
So, you’ve done all the preparation and
practised your English a lot, and now you
want to know what you can do during the exam.
Here are five tips to help you get the best
mark in your next speaking exam.
Number one: Remember, it’s not a race - so slow down!
Before you speak, think carefully about what you want to say and speak a little slower than normal.
Number two: If you don’t understand the
question or the activity, don’t worry.
Ask the examiner to explain it again.
You can say something like,‘Could you repeat
that, please?’
Number three: When you’re asked a question, don’t just say ‘yes’ or ‘no’ as
your answer.
The examiner wants to know how good your English is!
So, try to explain your answer with a reason.
Say ‘Yes, I agree because ...’ or ‘No,
I don’t think so, because …’
Number four: Look at the examiner’s or other students’ faces and eyes when you speak.
Faces can tell you a lot!
If you see that the examiner or your partner
don’t understand you, then say it again
using different words.
And finally number five: Speak clearly so
that the examiner can hear you.
If you find this difficult, practise with
a friend at home.
Stand at opposite ends of a room and speak to each other in English.
Or speak to each other in English online or on the phone.
OK - so these are our top five tips - but
just one final piece of advice.
Your teacher or examiner are only human - and usually they will really want you to do well.
So, take a deep breath, smile, relax and …. good luck with your next speaking exam!
For more tips on learning English, why not
subscribe to our channel and visit the LearnEnglish
Teens Website for more learning material!